chief White House and Washington
correspondent major Garrett is here in
Hanoi with me and major I know these
things are being floated sure but the
person who makes the decision on whether
North Korea has done anything to warrant
a u.s. concession is President exactly
why are we here
the it's not that the u.s. and North
Korea haven't negotiated over nuclear
weapons programs for a long time they
have the President believes that that
process which always started at the
lower levels and tried to move which way
up was wrong it has to start at the top
that's the president's whole perspective
a personal relationship is what's key to
resolving all of these underlying issues
that's why he is so intensely
personalized this issue the problem is
that personal relationship whatever
bonding has occurred hasn't produced
concrete results remember in Singapore
where do you tell us right after the
summit there'd be inspectors in North
Korea hasn't happened that there'd be a
reversal from North Korea's
long-standing human rights abuses that
hasn't happened either so when the
president talks about the success being
a personal relationship here in Hanoi it
has to translate to something more
practical more concrete the White House
knows that getting to those concrete
definitions and a process to move in
that direction is what noise is all
about and they're already floating this
idea that there could be a third summit
I think there is almost guaranteed
there'd be a third summit here senior
administration officials tell me this is
not going to be the place where the deal
is created it's going to be where
perhaps some orientation toward next
steps will be laid out we agreed to do
this and after that and after that then
there'll be another summit to keep
moving this process forward remember the
North Koreans love process they've shown
that with Americans for decades they're
all about process president Trump is all
about immediate results that itself is
part of the clash it is interesting
because also as these talks happen and
the normal
of Kim happens some of that pressure the
US has asserted comes off because now
you're not necessarily on the bad list
of the United States if you're doing
business with Kim Jong and look what
we're doing right now